hey Gary uh you talked a lot about 5149
yeah giving more than you're getting for
the longest time I did not do that yeah
and do you have any advice on besides us
have you started have I started when you
said for the longest time I I did not do
that
does that were you alluding to you've
started doing a little bit or you're
doing it yes for a while I've been
giving more than I'm getting what's
happening that it's a lot better the
questions do you have any tips in
speeding that process up nope just
patience alright thanks man appreciate
it but you know it's cool right like of
course it worked
dude cuz it's the right thing you seem
pretty fit you have any advice how to
get [ __ ] abs in one day that's
actually you know 20 I've been like I
made one video and I'm about to get real
like I'm about to really go hard at the
fitness industry like the contradiction
of between the business and the actual
skills to get into shape they talk
nothing about tried-and-true on the like
eat well workout every day
and results happen but then on the
business side they're like all right
like what's the [ __ ] speed up
mechanism it's just patience and it's by
the way you know pisses me off about
this conversation in a different level
how old are you you know like if you
[ __ ] were patient as [ __ ] for the
next 14 years you'd be my age patience
and and again I did it from 20 to 30
I built a business from 3 to 65 million
and I was paying myself $47,000 a year
that's real patients when and we were
there's a group of guys in your 20s and
30s were that money where I could pay
myself a million a year where that money
is the leverage to do things that makes
us want what we have which is girls and
friends and fun I was the mo i was the
singular most patient because i knew
every dollar that i would have taken out
to go to Vegas and have a fun time was a
dollar I wasn't putting into my business
to make more later and I was like I'm 20
I'll be 30 right but I had a punt
certain things and maybe even too much
in hindsight maybe
couple trips the Vegas would have done
me some good but but dude you're 26 like
by the way this is the old the second
you make it go faster the second go 49
51 is the second it stops coming in
I